- Vielen Dank. Bis dann!
- Hey!
- Hallo! Die Al-Paschas haben uns
für heute Abend zum Essen eingeladen.
- Ja? Wirklich?
- Als Dankeschön für den
Flohmarkt und das Fahrrad.
- Bin ich auch eingeladen?
- Ja, wieso nicht? Ich dachte, du
bist mit Selma befreundet.
- Ja, schon.
- Was machst du?
- Ich erkundige mich nur
nach Benimmregeln in Syrien.
Mir ist heute schon etwas Peinliches
passiert. Das reicht.
Hier steht: „Wenn Sie eine
syrische Familie begrüßen,
sollte der Mann der Frau
nicht die Hand geben.
Das ist unüblich und
gilt als unhöflich.
Außerdem wird sich nach
dem Befinden der Familie erkundigt.“
- Wir kennen die Familie
überhaupt nicht.
- Ja und? Hier steht,
es gehört sich so.
- Du nimmst das ganz schön ernst.
- Hm?
- Hat das etwas mit
dieser Selma zu tun?
- Nö … hmhm.
- Hallo, ich bin Yara.
- Ich bin Aya.
- Meine Frau.
- Freut mich sehr.
Vielen Dank für die Einladung.
- Selma, meine Tochter.
- Hallo!
- Hi!
- Hallo, ich bin Nico.
Freut mich, Sie kennenzulernen.
- Bitte, setzen Sie sich.
- Wir können uns gerne duzen.
- Wie geht es der Familie?
- Welcher Familie?
- Ja, eurer Familie.
- Ich denke, der Familie geht's gut.
Und, äh … deiner Familie?
- Ich denke auch.